[ Music ]
JEAN-FRANCOIS BILODEAU:
If you've ever had
that uneasy moment when
you suspect an endpoint is
compromised, but you don't yet
know how far the attacker got,
what they touched, or what to
do next, you're not alone.
Modern attacks move fast, and
without the right visibility
and response tool, small signals
can turn into major incidents.
Let me introduce you to a
course where you will learn how
to tackle these real-world
scenarios using Microsoft
Security Operations Platform.
Hello and welcome.
We're glad you could join us.
My name is
Jean-Fancois Bilodeau,
a Microsoft Technical Trainer.
In this session, we'll cover how
to mitigate threats using
Microsoft Defender for Endpoint,
how it fits into
Microsoft Defender XDR,
and how you can use it to
prevent, detect, investigate,
and respond to advanced
Endpoint threats.
By the end, you'll understand
the core capabilities
of Defender for Endpoint, how
to deploy and onboard devices,
how to harden Windows with
attack surface reduction,
how to investigate devices,
files, users, IPs, and domains.
We'll also take a look
at automation, alerting,
and detection
tuning, indicators,
and vulnerability management,
so you can reduce risk
and respond confidently when
something suspicious happens.
So let's get started
with this session.
Here we set the stage for
defending against cyber threat
with Microsoft Security
Operation Platform.
Let's take a look at where this
session fits into your journey.
Learning Path 4 focuses
on mitigating threats using
Microsoft Defender for Endpoint,
the Endpoint detection
and response platform
that helps security teams
investigate attacks take action
across devices in the industry.
Here's what we'll cover.
We'll start by protecting
against threat
with Microsoft Defender
for Endpoints,
then move into
deploying Defender
for Endpoint environment.
From there, we'll implement
Microsoft Security Enhancement,
perform device investigation,
and take action
directly on a device.
Next, we'll investigate
evidence and entity,
configure Manage Automation, and
then we'll configure for alert
and detection, including
tuning and indicators.
Finally, we'll wrap up
by utilizing threats
and vulnerability management
to continuously understand
and reduce exposure
across your Endpoints.
Now we begin the first module,
Protecting Against Threat
with Microsoft
Defender for Endpoint.
As with any technical training
content, keep in mind
that this material can evolve
as the product evolves,
and we'll want to
validate detail
against current documentation
when implementing in production.
After completing this
module, you should be able
to do three key things.
First, define the capabilities
of Microsoft Defender
for Endpoint.
Second, describe how to hunt for
threats within your network.
And third, understand
how Defender
for Endpoint can
help remediate risk
in your environment once
a suspicious activity
is identified.
Microsoft Defender for Endpoint
is a platform designed
to help enterprise network
prevent, detect, investigate,
and respond to advanced
threats on their Endpoint.
The flow starts with onboarding.
Devices are brought into
the service through one
of the supported
management tools.
Once onboarded, those devices
begin providing signal,
and they can also receive
response instructions
through Microsoft Defender
for Endpoint signal data.
In many organizations,
managed devices are joined
to and/or enrolled
in Microsoft Entra.
While unmanaged devices are
not joined to Entra ID,
four domains join Windows
device synchronization
into Entra ID is typically
handled using Entre ID Connect.
With that foundation in place,
the alerts, investigation,
and response action for Defender
for Endpoint are
managed centrally
in Microsoft Defender XDR.
If you want a deeper
architecture walkthrough,
there's also a supporting video
titled Microsoft Defender
for Endpoint Architecture,
which runs about six minutes.
Here we see a practical outcome.
Microsoft Defender for Endpoint
detecting a malicious payload
on a compromised endpoint.
The key idea is that endpoint
signals and analytics combine
to surface suspicious behavior
and known bad
indicators quickly.
So responders can move from
detection to investigation
and containment before
the attack spreads.
This content is aligned with
early learning path material,
reinforcing the same detection
and response story end to end.
Let's take a look at what
security operation feels
like in Defender for Endpoint.
Its detection and response
capabilities provides advanced
attack detection and are near
real-time and actionable.
When a threat is detected,
the system creates alert
for an analyst to
investigate then alert
that shares the same attack
technique or that are attributed
to the same attackers
that are aggregated
into a higher level entity
called an incident.
That aggregation matters because
it helps analysts investigate
and respond to threats
collectively instead
of chasing individual
alerts in isolation.
All of this is guided by
an assume breach mindset.
Defender for Endpoint
continuously collects behavioral
cyber telemetry, such as process
information, network activities,
deep visibility into the
kernel and memory manager,
user sign-in activity, and
changes to the registry
and file system, amongst others.
If you'd like to see incident
investigation in action,
there's a supporting
incident investigation video
and a Microsoft Learn
page that walks
through the incident
investigation process.
Next, we move into deploying
the Microsoft Defender
for Endpoint Environment,
setting up the service,
onboarding devices, and
configuring the environment
so your team can start
receiving meaningful signal
and taking a response action.
After completing this
module, you'll be able
to create a Microsoft Defender
for Endpoint Environment onboard
devices so they can be monitored
and configured key
environment setting
that govern how the service
operates in your organization.
Let's start with creating
your environment.
Administration and
investigation happens
in a Microsoft
Defender XDR portal
at security.microsoft.com.
During provisioning,
your tenant's geolocation
determines the data storage
location, and it's important
to note that you can't change
that location after setup.
In terms of data retention,
Defender for Endpoint Data
is returned for 180 days.
But when you use the
advanced hunting query,
access is available for 30 days.
You can also choose whether
preview features are enabled.
By default, they're on.
And you can change that later.
A practical tip, if the Defender
XDR portal, selecting any item
in the Endpoint section
or any Endpoint feature
will initiate the
onboarding experience.
That's all we need to do.
Finally, keep the service
footprint in mind.
Defender for Endpoint operates
in Microsoft Azure data center
in the European Union, the
United Kingdom, United States,
and other regions as well.
And customer data may be stored
in the tenant geo-identified
during provisioning,
or if another Microsoft
online service processes
that data according to the
service data storage rules.
Here, we walk through the
updated onboarding experience
of the Microsoft
Defender XDR portal.
You'll navigate to the assets
area and then into the devices
to start initializing
Defender for Endpoint.
During this process, you may
notice an in-progress message,
often shown with a coffee cup,
while the service prepares
to the environment and the
feature for your tenant.
Now let's take a look at
the device onboarding.
You'll go to the onboarding
section in the Defender
for Endpoint experience
to onboard any
supported device type.
Based on the platform you
choose, you'll be guided
through the right set of steps
and presented with management
and deployment tool option
that fits that device.
So the process is consistent,
whether you're using
enterprise management tooling
or a more direct method.
If you want a quick
visual walkthrough,
there's also a short supporting
video called Microsoft Defender
for Endpoint Onboarding
Client, and we'll also demo
that step later
on in this video.
As you plan onboarding,
it helps to be clear
on what platforms are supported.
Defender for Endpoints works
across Windows, macOS, Linux,
Android, and iOS, so you can
build consistent endpoint
visibility and response
across a diverse fleet.
Now, let's focus
on access control.
Defender for Endpoint uses the
Microsoft Defender XDR unified
role-based access control model,
giving you granular control
over what different
roles can see,
which devices they can access,
and what actions they can take.
You can control who is allowed
to take specific action
by creating custom role and then
selecting exactly which Defender
for Endpoint capabilities
those roles can use.
You can also control who
can see device information
by creating device
groups based on criteria
like the device name,
tag, domain, and more.
And then granting role access
to those device groups
through a specific Microsoft
Entra ID security group.
If you want a
guided walkthrough,
there's a supported video on
role-based access control
for Microsoft Defender
for Endpoint,
and we'll also demonstrate
this later on in this video.
Here we highlight a newer
approach to role management.
Permission options you can
assign including managed
security operation,
viewing data,
performing active
remediation action,
using live response capability,
investigating alert,
managing portal settings,
and managing security
posture setting.
What's important is
where this is done now.
Custom roles are set up in the
Microsoft Defender XDR settings,
bringing role configuration
into a single unified
place in the portal.
Device groups are a powerful way
to scope both visibility
and automation.
You can create device group and
then use them to limit access
to related alert and data to
specific Entra ID user groups
that have assigned RBAC role.
You can also configure different
auto-remediation settings
for a different set of devices
and assign specific
remediation level
that apply during
automated investigations.
During investigation,
device group become a
practical filter as well.
You can narrow the device list
to a specific group
using the group filter.
When you create a device group,
you'll set the automated
remediation level
for that group, specify
matching roles that determine
which device belong based on
things like the device name,
the domain, tags,
operating system platform,
select the Entra ID user
groups that should have access
to the device, and then rank
the device group relative
to other groups so overlap
is handled predictably.
With the environment in place,
let's shift into strengthening
Windows Endpoint.
In this module,
we'll take a look
at Windows security enhancement
that reduces the likelihood
of compromise and limit
what attackers can do
if they gain a foothold.
After completing this
module, you'll be able
to understand attack surface
reduction in Windows,
enable attack surface reduction
rules on Windows devices
and configure those rules
to match your organization risk
tolerance and operational needs.
Attack surface reduction
in Windows is broader
than just single control.
It's a collection of
capabilities designed
to reduce common attack paths.
These include attack
surface reduction rule,
hardware-based isolation,
application control,
exploit protection,
network protection,
Windows Defender
firewall, web protection,
control folder access, and
removable storage protection.
As you plan adoption,
Microsoft's guidance
on configuring attack
surface reduction capability
and which Windows
versions support
which features helps you
choose the right control
for a device fleet.
Now, let's get concrete with
attack surface reduction rule.
Some common examples include
blocking executable content
from e-mail client and webmail,
blocking all Office application
from creating child processes,
blocking Office app
from creating executable
content, blocking Office app
from injecting code into other
processes, blocking execution
of potentially
obfuscated script,
and using advanced protection
against ransomware.
Each rule can operate
in different mode.
Off, not configured or
disabled, which maps to zero.
Block, which enables the
rule maps to the number one.
Audit, mapping to two,
and warm, mapping to six.
That range is useful because
it lets you start with Audit
or Warn to automate impact
before enforcing block broadly.
For deployment, you can use
Microsoft Configuration Manager,
Group Policy, PowerShell,
Microsoft Intune,
or other mobile device
management option.
In a hands-on demonstration,
we're going to see later on how
to navigate the Endpoint
Manager Admin Center and work
through Endpoint security
policies to configure
and deploy these role modes.
Now that we've covered core
protection and hardening,
let's shift into investigation.
This is where Defender for
Endpoint helps you move
from something looks wrong
to a clear understanding
of what happened, what's
affected, and what to do next.
After completing this
module, you'll be able
to use the device page in
Microsoft Defender for Endpoint,
describe the device forensic
information that Defender
for Endpoint collects,
and explain how
behavioral blocking works
to stop threats based
on what they do,
not just what they look like.
Let's start with the
device inventory.
The device inventory page
shows you a list of devices
in your network where
alerts are generated.
By default, the list focuses
on device with alerts seen
in the last 30 days, which
helps you prioritize the most
recent risk.
In the current
portal experience,
you'll find this inventory
under the assets section,
specifically in devices.
When you pivot into
a specific device,
Defender for Endpoint gives you
an investigation workspace built
around the context and action.
You'll see each device detail,
a set of response action you can
execute, and a series of tabs
such as overview,
alerts, timeline,
security recommendation,
software inventory,
discovered vulnerability, and
missing knowledge base, KBs.
You'll also see
the summary cards
that helps you quickly orient
yourself, like active alerts,
logged on user, and a
security assessment,
so you can decide whether you're
dealing with a true incident
and what your next
step should be.
Now let's talk about
behavioral blocking
and containment on decline.
These capabilities help
identify and stop threats based
on behavior and process trees,
even when the threat has
already started running.
The idea is that next generation
protection, endpoint detection
and response, and Defender
for Endpoint components
work together.
Cloud intelligence and
local sensors combine
so suspicious behavior can be
blocked or contained quickly.
If you want an example
focused on this concept,
we'll see a couple of examples
in demos we'll run
later on in this video.
Investigation is
only half the story.
You also need the
ability to act.
Next, we'll focus on
the response action
so it can take directly on a
device, along with the option
to collect forensic data
and access system remotely
when deeper triaging
is required.
After completing this module,
you'll be able to perform action
on the device using Defender for
Endpoint, collect forensic data
to support an investigation,
and access device remotely using
built-in response capabilities.
When you're
investigating a device,
Defender for Endpoint gives you
device control so it can respond
without switching tools.
You can perform
action, collect data,
or remotely access the machine.
Common response action
includes managing tags,
initiating an automated
investigation,
starting a live
response section,
collecting an
investigation package,
running an antivirus scan,
restricting app execution,
isolating the device,
containing the device,
consulting a threat expert,
and reviewing the activity
in the Action Center.
One of the most useful
forensic options is collect an
investigation package.
As part of an
investigation or response,
you can gather a package that
includes things like autorun,
install program, network
connection, prefetch files,
running processes, scheduled
tasks, the security event log,
services, Windows Server,
message block session,
system information, temp
directories, users and groups,
and Defender support log, often
referenced as WD support logs.
This helps you capture a
snapshot of the device state
for deeper analysis and
evidence preservation.
For rapid, hands-on triage,
Live Response gives security
operation team a near-instant
access to a device through
a remote shell connection.
You can use basic command to
inspect what's happening.
Commands like connection, file
info, persistence, process,
registry, schedule
tasks, and services.
When you need deeper
capabilities,
advanced command helps you move
from observation to action.
Commands such as analyze,
get file, run, library,
put file, and remediate.
There's also a supporting
video on Microsoft Defender
for Endpoint Live Response
just over four minutes
that demonstrates
the experience.
Once you've
investigated the device
and taken immediate response
action, the next step is often
to pivot into the evidence
itself, files, user account,
IP addresses, domains, and URLs,
so you can understand scope,
impact, and potential
attacker infrastructure.
After completing this
module, you'll be able
to investigate file in Defender
for Endpoint, investigate domain
and IP addresses, and
investigate user account,
so you can correlate device
activity with identities
and external infrastructure.
Let's take a look at
file investigation.
When a file is associated with
an alert, suspicious behavior,
or notable event, you can
investigate its detail
to determine whether it
exhibits malicious activity,
identifies the
attacker's motivation,
and understand the potential
scope of the breach.
This is where you validate
whether the file is truly
harmful, whether it's
widespread, and how it connects
to the larger attack chain.
If you want to see deeper
analysis capability,
there's a supporting video
called the Microsoft Defender
for Endpoint Deep Analysis
and additional guidance
on a responding to file alert.
Identity is often
the real target,
so investigating user
account is critical.
You can identify accounts
which are the most active alerts
commonly shown as users at risk
on dashboards, and
investigate scenarios
like potentially
compromised credentials.
You can also pivot into a user
account directly from an alert
or device investigation
to look for patterns
such as lateral movement, where
the same user account appears
across multiple devices, or
suspicious sign-in activity,
such as account abuse.
When an IP address
shows up in telemetry,
investigating it helps you
determine whether it's benign,
suspicious, or
clearly malicious.
In the IP view, you can examine
where the IP is seen worldwide,
look up reverse DNS names,
review alerts related
to that IP, check whether the
IP appears in your organization
and understand prevalence.
How often is that IP is
observed in your environment?
Domain and URLs often
connect endpoint behavior
to attacker infrastructure.
In the URL and domain view,
you can review domain details
and register contact
information.
See Microsoft's verdict
and check incident related
to the URL or domain.
You can understand prevalence
within your organization
and see the most
recently observed device
that communicated with
that URL or domain.
Next, we'll focus on automation,
because at enterprise-scale,
consistent response
depends on smart default,
controlled remediation,
and integration
that helps enforce policy
without slowing down analysts.
After completing this
module, you'll be able
to configure advanced features
in Microsoft Defender
for Endpoint and manage
automation settings,
so investigation and remediation
can be scaled safely
across different device groups
and operational requirements.
Here we explore the
advanced feature area,
which provides a set
of on/off switches
for major feature
within the product.
In this context, we're focusing
specifically on the settings
that influences automation.
So you can decide whether
you want the service
to act automatically, where
you want human approval,
and what data source automated
investigation can use.
Automation quality
depends heavily
on what data automated
investigation can collect
and analyze.
With file content analysis,
you can enable a capability
where certain files and e-mail
attachments are automatically
uploaded to the cloud
for additional inspection during
an automated investigation.
With memory content analysis,
you can enable
automated investigation
of processed memory content.
When this is turned on, memory
content might be uploaded
to Microsoft Defender
for Endpoint as part
of an automated investigation.
You can also control what
automation should skip
by configuring automation
folder exclusion.
This exclusion lets
you specify folder
that automated
investigation will bypass,
and you can define attributes
such as the folder paths
themselves, file extension,
and file names for fine
tuning what gets excluded.
Now let's take a look at
automated investigation
and remediation level.
This is how you decide what
the system can fix on its own
versus what requires
approval from us.
Options include full,
where threats can be
remediated automatically,
and several semi-level
where approval is required,
such as requiring approval
for any remediation,
requiring approval for
curve folders remediation,
or requiring approval for
non-temp folder remediation.
If you want no
automated response,
you can also set a level
that disables automated
remediation action.
These settings are often
applied by device group,
so you can be more
aggressive where appropriate
and more cautious on
sensitive systems.
Here we connect Endpoint
Risk to access control
by using Microsoft
Defender Endpoint Manager
and conditional access to
block at-risk devices.
The flow starts by turning on
the Microsoft Intune connection
from the Microsoft
Defender XDR portal.
Next, you turn on the Defender
for Endpoint Integration
in the Intune Admin Center.
And then you create a
compliance policy in Intune,
assign that policy to the right
users or devices, and finally,
create a Microsoft Entra ID
conditional access policy
that can enforce
access decision based
on device compliance or risk.
There's also a supporting
video on conditional access
with Defender for Endpoint.
Now we'll focus on how alerts
are configured and managed.
Because detection
is only helpful
if the right people are
notified, noise is controlled,
and your indicators
and policies align
to how your
organization operates.
After completing this
module, you'll be able
to configure alert settings in
Microsoft Defender for Endpoint
and manage indicators so you
can improve signal-to-noise
and enforce blocking or auditing
for known indicators
of compromise.
Let's revisit advanced
feature from a detection
and investigation perspective.
This area provides
many on/off switch
that controls how Defender
for Endpoint connects
with other services and
how information is shared
across the broader
security stack.
So your alerting
and investigation
experience is unified.
Here are several key
integrations you can enable.
Microsoft Defender for Identity
Integration retrieves enriched
user and device data from
Defender for Identity
and forwards Defender
for Endpoint Signal,
improving correlation across
identities and endpoints.
Sharing endpoint alerts
with Microsoft Compliance Center
supports broader governance
and compliance workflow.
Microsoft Defender for Cloud
App can receive Defender
for Endpoint Signal, giving
administrators deeper visibility
into both sanctioned
Cloud Apps and Shadow IT.
The Microsoft Intune
Connector enables sharing
of device information and
stronger policy enforcement.
Web content filtering can be
enabled to help control access
to risky categories of content.
And Microsoft Secure Score
can receive Defender
for Endpoint Single, so Secure
Score reflects your device's
security posture and
improvement opportunities.
Here we look at how Defender
for Endpoint can notify the
right people at the right time.
You can configure the service
to send e-mail notification
to specific recipient whenever
new alerts are generated.
This ensures that the
appropriate responders are
immediately notified and
can take action based
on alert severity.
Configuration is
restricted to user
with the managed security
settings permission.
In environment using basic
permission management,
this typically includes
security administrator
or global administrator.
You can fine-tune which alert
severity level triggers
notifications and manage the
recipient list over time,
with new recipients only
receiving alerts generated
after they've been added.
Not every alert
represents a real risk,
and alert tuning helps
you reduce noise
without losing visibility.
Here, we explore how to create
tuning rules for alerts
that are known to be benign
in your environment,
such as an internally
developed tool
or a common
administrative process.
You can scope suppression rules
to a specific user, a device,
a device group, so only matching
alerts are suppressed while
others remain visible.
In scenarios that requires
broader suppression,
such as an organization-wide
benign tool,
administrators can suppress
alert across all devices.
This approach helps
analysts stay focused
on meaningful threats instead
of chasing expected activity.
Indicators of
compromise, or IoC,
are a foundational capability
in endpoint protection.
Defender for Endpoint
allows security teams
to define indicators and enforce
action, such as allowing,
auditing, blocking,
or remediating activities
tied to those indicators.
You can manage IOCs for
files, IP addresses, URLs,
domains, and certificates.
This enables proactive
blocking of known threats,
consistent enforcement
across devices,
and tighter control during
incident responses.
There is also a supporting
video on unified IOCs
that demonstrates how those
indicators work together
across the platform.
With detection and response
covered, we now shift
into understanding and
reducing exposure.
Microsoft Defender Vulnerability
Management Tool helps you
continuously identify weaknesses
across your environment,
providing visibility
into vulnerabilities
before they're exploited.
After completing this
module, you'll be able
to describe how vulnerability
management works in Defender
for Endpoint, identity
vulnerabilities in your devices,
and track emerging threats
so remediation can be
prioritized effectively.
Defender Vulnerability
Management uses built-in
and agentless scanners
to continuously monitor
and detect risk, even when
devices aren't connected
to the corporate network.
This capability provides
near real-time insights
into vulnerabilities,
misconfiguration,
and exposure trends.
The goal is to help security
team move from reactive patching
to proactive risk reduction.
There's also an interactive
guide available that walks
through threats
and vulnerability
management end-to-end.
Here we explore how
vulnerability data is organized
and consumed.
The vulnerability management
navigation pane provides
multiple views,
including a dashboard
with overall exposure
scores, threat awareness,
and top recommendation.
You can drill into
security recommendations
to see effective software,
remediation option,
and threat context.
Remediation view helps track
active fixes and exceptions,
while inventory
provides visibility
into all organizational assets.
Additional view highlights
known weaknesses, recent events
that impacts risk, and
baseline assessment
for compliance monitoring.
Once risks are identified,
remediation follows
a clear flow.
You select a recommendation,
submit a remediation request,
and then review progress
as fixes are implemented.
This structured
approach helps security
and IT team collaborate
effectively
and track risk
reduction over time.
Now, let's see Defender
for Endpoint in action.
Welcome to our Defender
for Endpoint demo.
In this demo, what we're going
to do is set up
device onboarding.
We're going to onboard a
device, and following that,
let's configure a role,
and we'll also configure
a device group.
We're already logged into
Defender for Endpoint,
so let's begin by setting
up Device Discovery.
We're going to go down to
"System Settings," and here,
let's go to "Device Discovery,"
and let's make sure
that standard discovery
is turned on.
It's already turned
on by default.
So there's nothing to change.
So now we'll move to
"Onboarding a Device."
Let's head back to our settings.
Let's go to "Endpoints,"
scroll down,
and let's select "Onboarding."
Here we can choose what kind
of device we want on board.
Is it Windows?
Is it Linux?
Is it Mac?
Is it Android?
iOS? Choose whichever
device you want to use.
In our case, we're going
to go with Windows 11.
Connectivity type, we'll
leave it as "Streamlined."
There are different
methods that we can use
to deploy the onboarding,
Group Policy,
Microsoft Endpoint Configuration
Manager, amongst others.
But in our case,
we'll keep it simple.
We'll just go with
a local script.
It's not the most
scalable approach.
This is not what you want to use
across a large organization,
but adequate for a demo.
Let's download the script.
shouldn't take long,
and let's open it.
It's a zip file, so what
we'll do is we'll unzip it
in Explorer.
Right-click and "Extract."
Done. Next, let's run it.
We're going to run
it as administrator.
We need administrator
privileges.
Run as administrator.
Run. Yes. And there we go.
Let's confirm that, yes, we
want to onboard this device.
And we've successfully
onboarded this device
in Defender for Endpoint.
We can now close the window and
continue working as we see fit.
Now that we've onboarded
our device, let's verify
that it got onboarded
successfully.
What we're going to do here
is navigate to our assets,
select devices, and there we go.
There's Base23B.
That's the device we've
onboarded over here.
Let's run a test to make
sure it's running correctly,
that it's sending telemetry.
So we're going to go back to our
"System Settings," "Endpoints."
Let's scroll down to
"Onboarding" once again.
Scroll past the
onboarding strategy,
section two, run
a detection test.
We've got a command we can
run over here to test.
Make sure that the
onboarding was successful.
We'll copy that
to the clipboard.
Let's start a command prompt
using elevated privileges,
run as administrator.
Yes. And let's paste
the command in here.
"Execute."
The prompt automatically closed.
That's normal.
And done. We've issued the test.
And now let's see
if we successfully
simulated an attack.
All right, let's make
sure that our tests work.
We'll go down to "Incidents
and Alerts," "Incident,"
and there's the test alert,
suspicious PowerShell
command line.
Let's manage the incident and
mark it as a security test.
"Done." "Save."
So we've tested that
the device is onboarded
and also actioned
our first incident.
In this demo, let's set up a
security role and an assignment.
We're going to head back
down to our system settings.
Under "System Settings," let's
go to "Microsoft Defender XDR,"
"Permissions and Role."
Scroll down a little
bit, and there's go
to permissions and roles.
Let's create a custom role.
We'll use the name
tier one support.
Skip over the
"Description," "Next."
What permission group do I
want to assign our team?
Let's select
"Security Operation,"
and we'll give them all
read and manage permission.
"Apply." "Next."
Who do we want to
assign the role to?
Let's create an assignment.
We'll name the assignment
Tier 1 Support,
and let's assign this
to the group SG-IT.
"Done," "Add,"
"Next," and "Submit."
We've created our first role.
and we've done our first
assignment at the same time.
All right, in this demo,
let's create a device group,
add devices, and select who
can perform remediation.
So we're going to go down
to our "System "Settings."
Let's head into "Endpoints."
Let's select "Device Groups"
when we'll create our
first device group.
"Add," let's choose a name.
We'll simply call
this one regular.
Remediation level, let's
select "Full remediation."
Next, which devices should
be part of that group?
Let's keep it simple.
We're going to select all
of our Windows 11 devices.
"Select OS," "Windows
11," "Next."
We can preview which devices
would be in that group.
There's only one that's the
device we onboarded earlier
in this demo.
That's good.
"Phase 23B."
"Next." And finally, who can
perform remediation action
on that device?
Let's select our support team.
That will be SG-IT.
There's the group.
"Select." "Add Selected Groups."
"Submit." And we're done.
We've created our
first device group,
and now we can continue creating
additional device group,
reorder them as necessary.
Let's recap what we've covered
in this learning path.
We explored how Defender for
Endpoint helps prevent, detect,
investigate, and responds to
advanced endpoint threats.
We looked at threat management
through near real-time detection
and incident, device
onboarding, and configuration.
Attack surface reduction
to limit exposure,
and vulnerability management
to continuously identify
and reduce risk across
the environment.
This concludes our session.
There are many ways to continue
your learning journey.
We encourage you to watch other
videos in this course or search
out your next favorite topic on
Microsoft Learn at aka.ms/learn.